は)眠いよもう無理だよ～
た)目めちゃめちゃ赤いですよ
は)嘘？
こんばんは！
はじめしゃちょーと？
あ
そういうやつですか？
みなさん「GOSSO」
知っていますでしょうか？
一時期すごいみたいなかんｊ
汚なこれ。
パッケージ汚なｗ
ご覧ください
この女の鼻毛がごっそり。
結構有名ですよねでも
なんか一時期すごい
「うわっすごいこれがあれば
鼻毛がとれる！」
みたいなこうちょっと
巷でキャッキャキャッキャ
してたんですけど
この「GOSSO」っていうやつ
なにかといいますと
脱　毛　ワ　ッ　ク　ス
でございます
それも鼻毛専用…
両鼻10回分だって
レンジでチンして
溶けたやつを
こう鼻にぶっさして
ドゥン‼
ってやったら鼻毛が全部
とれるっていう
やつなんですけども
は)やったことある？
た)ない
でこれなんか使った人何人か
見たことあるんですけども
みんな本当に痛そうなんですよ
そこまでして鼻毛抜くんだったら
鼻毛カッターでジョリって
やればいいんじゃないかって
僕思ってて
ちょっとあの
まぁ不毛な…争いだと思ってるんですよ
というわけで
僕ちょっと考えたんですけども
人の痛覚が鈍っている瞬間って
必ずあると思うんですよ
それがいつかと言うと
多分普通にこう起きてる時に
ぶん殴られる時より
寝てるときに
ぶん殴られたほうがなんか
みたいな
痛覚より驚きの感情が
前に出てくるので
「GOSSO」も同じ考え方をすると
僕が寝てる時に
「GOSSO」をぶち込まれて
ブチッって
鼻毛を抜かれても
そんなに痛くないんじゃなないか
と思いまして
画期的だよ？
痛くないのに毛が全部抜けるっていう
ちょっと「GOSSO」の
新たな使い方になるのではないでしょうか今回
徹夜してて眠さの限界で
さらにそこでお酒をいれてるんで
今多分秒で寝れると思います
なので僕が死んだように寝ている間に
彼に「GOSSO」を準備してもらって
僕の鼻にぶっさして
抜いてもらおうと思います
ちょっと「GOSSO」の
準備だけしておきましょう
ハハハッハッハｗｗｗ
待って！すごいすごいすごい
チーク菓子みたいになってる
これを溶かすんだよ多分
ここに説明書が入っております
では僕は
え～二日分寝ようと思います
おやすみ！
耳栓をして寝ます
準備してる時にも多分
僕は何も聞こえないと思うんで
これでじゃあ寝ていこうと思います
では任せたぞ
じゃあおやすみたぬっち
「GOSSO」
作りまーす
いい感じだ
あっあっあっあっ×∞
(スーパー喘ぎタイム)
あっあっあっあっあっあ×∞
え？え？え？え？え？え？
(スーパー喘ぎタイム)
アッ
たぬっち食べて
アイャッブフゥゥゥ
えっえっあっほんとに⁉
あっほんとに？
アウゥゥゥゥ＠＊‘＃＄％